freunde jetzt willkommen zu einem video
ist es ganz ungewohnt für mich einfach
so vom computer zu sitzen aber ich bin
hier zusammen mit lugano wir machen im
geist der alten tage also quasi wie vor
zwei drei jahren einfach ein video wo
wir probieren youtuber an drei merkmalen
zu erraten wir haben ja den kanal von
high clubs gefunden ihn ganz groß
geschrieben
guckt euch gerne mein video an ich habe
euch das original auch unten verlegen
die versagen wir reden nicht lange rum
sondern wir legen los ich will all ihrer
ist einfach der verlieren hat einfach
verloren
ganz kurz bevor es richtig losgeht
dieses videos unterstützt von amazon
prime video also seid sehr aufmerksam
ihr könnt geschenke im wert von bis zu
500 euro gewinnen ok nummer 1 kommt
alles mount everest business coaching
wie kant natürlich wie kamst du bitte
was hat er den mount everest zu tun bin
hat sich das lied gemacht
ich kenne das einfach nicht dieses jahr
ihren aufruf nein das war dieser mir
sorgen dass dann halt auch wieder was
mit ins boot zu tun
ich kenne die sitcom das auf
wahrscheinlich hast du dann recht glatze
business coaching kann ja eh nur einer
sein jack alles richtig
richard milne umarmen oder hat so viel
krank und er hat schon verschiedene
business ist auf jeden fall also der
mehrere business also business hat er
mehrere
ganz kurz ok nummer zwei ich bin sehr
gespannt diesmal höchsten punkt mary
mary wer geht es oft um thomas den
ehemaligen pater thomas riedinger ich
habe es nur an selbst experimente rella
der heißt omari-moschee das war krieg
und warum revie arbeitete vorherigen
haben vom revier genau der war der kater
von risiko interviews
lieber ihr müsst wissen wir sind gerade
eben bevor wir das video klickt mal
drüber gehabt das stand schon lieber und
interviews punkt aber da wir aber
rollstuhl spätestens da war es klar die
aber auch ihren mann jetzt ist es gar
nicht die nummer vier man muss
eigentlich direkt beim ersten raten
channel
ich wusste das ist ein wunder dass dein
vater ist ich habe war es muss ja schon
selber haben einfach eine la motte
durchgegangen und dann hat es mir sehr
hey ich weiß dass niemand von denen
kindheit und verschenkt wusste ist halt
einfach nicht alter was macht er da mit
der kamera ich weiß einfach weg kostet
2000 euro
da lernt man noch was dazu ok insgeheim
ex-klub real das muss eigentlich traurig
sein glaube ja macht er klar versuchte
das irgendwie krass ich habe so ein
installer foto gesehen wurde auch
gespielt hat ich glaube du hast recht ja
verdammt
da bin ich aber los gewesen wie steht's
denn jetzt drei zu zwei für dich ja ja
ja gleich mehrere business business das
ja genau
[Musik]
happy sehr viel performance rohr
es ist das zweite was kommt ja aber ich
finde cap ist schon typisch gps musste
die a4 mikrowelle mit dem cap jetzt
sieht ja er war ja ich hätte hier ohne
cap ausblick genossen wir leben wie cher
hat mein leben war schon mal abgesehen
nicht stimmt wunsch oder studien ist
mein gott ich wusste ja ich wusste nicht
mal das ja werden warum haselnuss pocket
asse pocket asse hobbs genommen um den
haselnuss hazel und sie hat doch das
steuer video für julien berger hat weil
sie ja steuerberaterin vor das war aber
wirklich schwer herr warte mal was ich
bin kran hoch ein sprecher ich bin hier
die nachrichten es gibt jetzt zu gewinn
und zwar im gesamtwert von über 500 euro
deshalb würden sie sehr verehrte damen
und herren ihre ohren ganz weit
aufsperren
sie fanden es vielleicht warum ich ihnen
das erzähle der sehr berühmte gut auf
sinne und reichelt youtuber krankhafter
hatte gemeinsam mit seinem weniger
reichen weniger gut aussehen oder es die
möglichkeit für die zuschauer auf dem
videokanal geschenke zu gewinnen anders
hierfür war der serienstart der
unglaublich guten das sage ich als kran
hoch war komplett unabhängig serie
die spiele werden ja oder entspannen ist
sehr spannend und sehr unterhaltsam
dafür stehe ich mit meinem namen gerufen
haben und weil die tiere krank waren
offiziere ist wirklich anders und alter
wir müsst ihr euch wirklich anschauen
das sage ich nicht einfach nur so
sondern wirklich mega heiß gewesen hat
seine sparte machten weder zuschauern
wird auch die drei vermissten frau einen
videokanal sehr viel spaß gemacht total
ende alle die da gut aussehender junger
spund für seine zuschauer gewinnen
können die zuschauer gewinnen um ein
zwei leute gewinnen sehr gut hierfür
müssen sie nur auf den link in der video
beschreibung oder in der end card gehen
auf den msn video kanal und hersteller
lcn krampfader kommentieren eine sehr
einfache aufgabe außerdem müssen sie
zählen wie viele produkte dieser
teufelskerl für seine zuschauer gewinnen
konnte tut dies weil ihr euch jetzt tut
zum einem gedenken die alle vorderseite
ist ab dem 18
dezember verfügbar und ich gebe zurück
zum besten video aller zeiten ganz kurz
sie hat das steuer video für giulia
siegel hat auch komplett falsche steuer
video und darauf reagiert maria talent
hat er nicht richtig gestellt was er
falsch gericht das hat er dann so
millionen von aufrufen dann der 24 23
montavista wasser ich habe die ganze
zeit nachgedacht aber messi und barca
trikot und schwester natürlich 15.30
muss die letzten beiden runden gewinnen
ich zitiere hier gerade davon gehören
[Musik]
hey hey hast du schon idee das ist schon
eine idee hast du irgendeine idee
fernsehens nica und irgendwie kommt auch
kein youtube aus münchen war die team
aber der ist auch in berlin oder ist er
auch ist so kai pflaume ist rennen aber
doch still glaubst du ich war mir
wirklich nicht sicher aber ist wenn ich
keine flamme ist deren flamme naja wie
dahin
also wir haben für mich alles oder gar
nichts tim gabel von xxx alter mann
[Musik]
ich dachte es wäre dieser michaels
monika dann habe ich es milow docs ist
doch die marke von zeigen rufe das kann
nur einer sein
das konnte nur einen starter können wir
schon durchs gitter
ich muss direkt dran bleiben julia
beauty queen david katar dabei
ich war ein bisschen schneller oder
katja hab mir mal wieder hin sagt komm
crafter justin als jaja wollte ein graf
ich wollte erste nehmen aber dann dachte
ich minecraft wort minecraft als erster
okay ich glaube er baut es immer so auf
dass es jede runde ein bisschen
schwieriger wird somit jeder erstmal das
ist leicht auf jetzt 8 ball an ich
glaube es war herr newstime was hat er
mit thomas gottschalk sie hatten thomas
gottschalk bild im internet ist
hundertprozentig in houston
nichts von gehört oder gemacht dennoch
was überhaupt ich weiß dass gar nicht
ehrlich gesagt ich habe nur seine rede
von artikel 13
ich sage ist er auch ich sagen stern tv
cooper war sehr sehr gut wirken sondern
das bild
okay es gibt ganz kaputt booster mussten
sie sein aber wie steht es denn jetzt
viel zu wenig für mich huber hat und
ganz alten kollegen romans von
produziert also ja ich habe mich so
richtig erschrocken als es mir gerade
eingefallen ist ja wie viele business
hat karl es mehrere mehrere business
ich kann einfach nur gewinnen leute ich
kann einfach nur gewinnen hat mir die
usa lässt